وتنضم الينا من البنتاجون نائبه المتحدث
باسم البنتاجون سبرينا سينج اهلا بك
صبرينا سينجلي نبدا اولا بالجهه المسؤوله
عن
الهجوم امس ومن اين انطلق
والمعلومات معلوماتكم حول
ذلك شكرا جزيلا لاستضافته طبعا اولويتنا
في وزاره الدفاع هو هو
ما حصل يوم امس مقتل ثلاثه جنود ليله امس
ونازل نقيم هذا الهجوم من قام به لدينا
مؤشرات اوليه بان هذا سلوك نمطي لحزب الله
ونعرف ان هناك مجموعات مدعومه من ايران
وتدرب وتحصل على السلاح
والدعم العسكري والمالي من ايران فيما
يتعلق بالخطوات التاليه كما شاهدتم الوزير
والرئيس قال بان سنرد بالوقت المناسب الذي
نختاره وت لي انا لن اسبق ما يقولونه
وينتظر قرار الرئيس في الايام القادمه نعم
ولكن سبر بالتاكيد يعني تابعتي رد الفعل
الايراني الرسمي الذي نفى تماما علاقته
بهذا
الهجوم نحن نعم بالتاكيد قرات هذه
التقارير وما قالت ايران من انكار نعلم
بان ايران تمول و وتمول وتدرب وتمد
بالسلاح مجموعات مثل حزب الله والحوثيين
ونعلم بانه يستمرون تزويدهم بالاسلحه
والقدرات وحتى قبل اسبوعين
احد سفنا
البحريه جرى
وايقافها
وكانت لمنع حصول في مزيد من الاسلحه
وبالتالي فلنعلم ان المصدر هو ايران
والمصدر جغرافيا من اين
انطلق هذا امر ما زلنا ندرسه لحد الان
نحاول نحدد بالضبط نقطه الانطلاق ليس
لدينا تفاصيل ذلك حاليا ا وعندما توفر
مزيد من المعلومات سوف اقدمها لكم سرور
طيب بالنسبه للرد تحدثت قبل قليل صبرينا
سينج عن اننا سنرد في الوقت المناسب الوقت
المناسب والمكان المناسب يعني ماذا كيف
سترد واشنطن على هذا
الهجوم شكرا جزيلا لهذا السؤال فهذا
السؤال وجهيه للغايه وهذا الرئيس هو الذي
سيقرر الامر هو القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه وهو اللي سيقر ماه ما هي الوقت
المناسب ليقوم ليقوم
الجيش الامريكي بالرد على الهجوم الذي حصل
امس والهجمات التي شهدناها على القوات
الامريكيه في العراق
وسوريا وطبعا لابد لا داع اذكركم في
تعلمون ذلك ل ان هنا اننا موجود هناك
للتاكد من الهزيمه الكامله والنهائيه
لداعش وهم حاليا ليس بقوه ما كانوا عليه
سابقا طبعا نسبق الرئيس فهو يتناقش ذلك مع
فريقه الاستشار الامني والرئيس والوزير
اوستن كان هناك معه التقى بفريق الامن
القومي وناقشت ما حصل امس وطبعا اهم شيء
درسوه ما هو الطريق الى الامام ما هي
القرارات اللي يتخذونها وانا بالتاكد
اسبقهم في ذلك نعم لكن سبرينا سينج
يعني يعني واشنطن تصر على ان هذه الحرب في
غزه ولكن انتم تاخذون ايضا هذه
المواجهات في لبنان وهي جبهه ساخنه في
العراق في سوريا في في اليمن وكل هذا بسبب
دعمكم مصالح امريكا تتعرض لهذه الهجمات
بسبب موقف امريكا الداعم لاسرائيل اليس
كذلك علينا ان نتذكر لماذا نحن هنا لماذا
ندعم اسرائيل اسرائيل تعرض لهجوم
الس من اكتبر على يد منظمه ارهابيه قامت
باختطاف وقتل اشخاص ابرياء واسرائيل فعلا
لديها حق الرد ولا بد التالي نحن ان ندعم
اسرائيل ونتاكد نتمتع بالقرات اللازمه
لاخراج حماس من غزه كما ان اوضحنا في
حديثنا مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه وقوات
الدفاع الاسرائيليه بانه لابد ان يحترموا
القوانين الانسانيه وقوانين النزاعات
المسلحه وقد سمعت من هذا المبل بشكل علني
وحتى بشكل خاص في محادثاتنا انتقدنا لهم
ذلك ان الوزير
ونظرائه في اسرائ يتحدثون تقريبا يتفادون
الحديث تقريبا يوميا وبالتالي فهذا امر
يفكر به ويهتم به الوزير و نواصل حث
اسرائيل السماح المساعدات الانسانيه
بالوصول لان الناس الذين يقون هناك لابد
ان يحصل على مساعده يحتاجونها وان ولا بد
من توفير حمايه المرات الانسانيه نن واصل
الحث على
ذلك لا نخفي حقيقه بان المنطقه فعلا في
توتر عالي جدا ونحن لا نريد ان اي طرف
يستغل الوضع الموجود في اسرائيل وغزه
ويخلق نزاعا اقليميا اوسع هذا ليس ما
نريده ولا ولاع ايران تريده ايضا ولهذا
السبب فاننا ايضا كنا محدودين جدا ودقيقين
جدا في ردودنا وسنواصل الرد في المكان
والطريقه المناسبه التي نختارها حسب اوامر
الرئيس طيب يعني هناك اصرار امريكي على ان
الامور بدات يوم السابع من اكتوبر مع انه
الامر في مجمله يتعلق بالاحتلال
الاسرائيلي للاراضي الفلسطينيه لكن السؤال
هو الى اي مدى سيستمر هذا الدعم الامريكي
سياسيا وعسكريا لاسرائيل خصوصا ونحن نشهد
هذا التوسع الاقليمي
للنزاع واير ليس لدي جدول زمني حول
المساعدات الامريكيه ولكن ما اطع قوله ان
الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم اسرائيل في
محاربتها للمنظمات
الارهابيه والتي ما زالت
تقاتل تحجز رهاء في
غزه نحن نقوم مساعدات اسرائيل في قتالها
ايضا نحث على ان تسمح بالمساعدات
الانسانيه بالوصول الى غزه وانا نعلم ان
هناك العديد والعديد من الناس ال حاج
غدات الطبيه وان نحث اسرائيل على قيام ذلك
وان نحث علىشكل خاص ان تحترم القوانين
الانسانيه وقوانين النزاعات المسلحه شكرا
جزيلا لك سبرينا سين نائبه المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون شكرا جزيلا
لك